Great game, right?
So you're probably expecting me to crash a car or blow something up.
But really, I'm here to talk about car safety.
Look around you.
Who do you see?
Friends, family, neighbors, all your loved ones.
Everyone you care about.
And here's what I want you to do.
I want you to give each and every one of them a hug.
I'll wait.
Thank you.
Those people you just hugged, they're real.
They're not crash test dummies.
They're not engineering data.
And their safety matters as much to Honda as it matters to you.
And it's why Honda builds more top safety rated cars in America than any other brand.
You can let go now, friend.
That's a great hug.
Oh, thanks.
Thank you.